so if i were magnus in terms of the
clock situation
i would simply oh wow okay he has
stepped back with his bishop but
this feels like a step too far for
magnus carlsen black can just step
okay look at the bar uh black's now got
a big advantage if he just moves his
rook down one square
block the attack against his knight and
he finds it
ah and magnus reacts he didn't see it
he didn't even realize that was possible
unbelievable
oh well was turn around because now
magnus
having played such a fantastic
game has now just squandered it all away
and now it's lavon
who is i don't see a way for lavonne
sorry i don't see a way for magnus to
even think about holding this game it's
just too much
he's in huge trouble right now look at
magnus's face he did not even realize
that black could block that attack with
his rooken now if we just do a quick
count that's all we need to do
black has a rook for white's bishop
queens are off the board there won't be
any checkmates rook is a better